jean luc reichmann jean luc reichmann
s'est exprimé pour la première fois à la
télévision depuis le début d'al sadd a
éclaté le 27 mars dernier
on rappelle que l'ancien maître dès midi
a été placé en détention pour détention
de milliers d'imagés pédo
pornographiques sur ses ordinateurs
merci mais à sea dogs juste avant le
débris de cette interview vous a préparé
un résumé sur la relation leur
allocation qui avec jean luc reichmann
avec son ancien maître de midi ils
étaient très très proches et juste après
on va revenir sur les déclarations de
jean luc reichmann
voilà je vous le dis c'est passé à 19
heures on a l'image là c'était dans ses
caves où on va vous montrer toujours un
truc là d'intelligent à dire dessus dans
la sphère quesada beaucoup de médias ont
attendu la réaction de jean-luc
reichmann animateur emblématique des 12
coups de midi il avait exprimé dans un
tweet peu de temps après le début de la
sphère la rage qu'il ressentait suite à
l'arrestation de l'ancien champion de
son jeu cette rage qui s'empare de moi
aujourd'hui m'incite plus que jamais à
continuer mes combats dont celui de
protéger et d'accompagner au mieux nos
enfants une rage d'autant plus
compréhensible que les deux hommes
étaient devenus proches leur première
rencontre s'est déroulée le 4 juillet
2016 alors que christian quesada foulé
pour la première fois le plateau du jeu
vient de hongrie létard tata au foyer de
deux enfants des rues de face à ce
candidat et rudy qui écrase ses
adversaires par sa culture l'animateur
admiratif offre une place de choix à
christian à l'antenne au fil des
victoires les deux hommes apprennent à
se connaître et à s'apprécier vraiment
le sentiment de prendre une leçon à
chaque fois mais mais ça sert non mais
c'est une belle personne en plus parce
qu'il faut avoir beaucoup de de qualité
ou de reichmann ira même jusqu'à lui
faire l'honneur de l'inviter à ses côtés
pour co animer un prime spécial sur tf1
côtoient professeurs
christian grands gagnants des jeux de
l'acquérir
une situation qui aide à comprendre le
désarroi et l'immense trahison ressenti
par l'animateur à l'annonce de ce fait
divers et des agissements de christian
quesada ce soir l'animateur a finalement
décidé de sortir de son silence
médiatique et de prendre la parole pour
la toute première fois
alors on va vous montrer des images de
jean luc reichmann alors jean-luc
reichmann s'est exprimée donc sur le
plateau de ses tabous il a commencé par
faire part de sa colère toujours intacte
depuis que l'affairé a éclaté regarde
ailleurs il est toujours aussi fort bien
sûr parce qu'on parle beaucoup d'un
individu et on parle pas de victimes
on parle pas d'enfant on est père de
famille ici on est mère de famille j'ai
créé la brigade des mineurs
leo matiz brigade des mineurs et lorsque
vous avez la brigade des mineurs qui le
lui en demain de cette affaire m'appelle
en direct sur mon téléphone à lézat bête
c'est vrai ce que je vous dis j'aime 10
mai jean luc on a besoin de gens comme
toi parce que tu as parole n'est pas
plus forte que nous elle est dix fois
plus forte 100 fois plus forte
mille fois plus forte cet individu a
deux petits enfants en bas âge on n'en
parle pas une et si vous vous imaginez
nous sommes responsables ici je peux les
faire mais qui a refusé nous parce que
ces gens l'utilisent et matthieu
delormeau qui parlait pendant voilà
pendant l'extrait jeudi qu'il avait
beaucoup beaucoup parlé ce soir
il manie pardon de m'intéresser voilà
vous raconte tout alors jean luc
reichmann donc qui s'est exprimé êtes
vous surpris déjà qu'ils aient choisi de
s'exprimer dans ses tableaux pourquoi ne
pas avoir sollicité mc kay dans le
groupe tf1 c'est vrai et ça c'est
sébacées ce que j'aime chez jean-luc
voilà et je vous le dit jean lui qu'il
aurait adoré venir nous voir ici dans
touche pas à mon poste malheureusement
tf1 ne va pas laisser l'autorisation de
venir mais je t'embrasse fort agent lui
que j'ai eu ce week end encore par sms
et c'est vrai que voilà il est
extrêmement sincère dans ce qu'il dit
valérie je trouve effectivement très
étonnant qu'il n'ait pas réservé sa
première parole qui était extrêmement
attendu à quotidien qui éteint le
magazine du groupe sur lequel il aurait
pu s'exprimer donc
pour quelles raisons sage de l'ignorent
mais en tout cas c'est assez étonnant et
ça montre aussi la liberté d'esprit de
jean luc reichmann
alors oui il n'a pas prononcé une seule
fois le nom de christian qu'elle soit là
il n'y arrive pas je vous lis dans cette
émission durant toute l'interview il a
expliqué pourquoi il est comme ça qu'ils
aient fait qui s'est fait gauler cet
individu est prodigue puis son nom vous
dit non mais évidemment mais évidemment
si l horreur quel dégoût survie de vomir
évidemment voilà c'est tout moi pascal
et je croyais pas qu'il allait autant
donner à ces mêmes isabelle je pense que
il est trahi évidemment les textos qui
nous a envoyé aux uns ou aux autres
traduisez ça d'une façon extrêmement
importante se tourn même scandaleux
honnêtement qu'on puisse mettre en cause
le fait qu'il était au courant parce que
évidemment quand on le connaît c'est
impossible et impensable surtout
qu'effectivement il travaille avec la
brigade des mineurs manquant tout volé
au match ici c'est à vous je pense qu
nettement cette démission là ils avaient
besoin de l'émission la plus neutre
vous savez qu'il allait pouvoir parler
de faire un deuil nous étant un cas à
part qu'il allait pouvoir passer de la
façon la plus longue sans être
interrompus yann barthès étant beaucoup
plus donc beaucoup plus aux prises le
genre de programme de jean luc reichmann
l'on peut dire c'est pas une valeur à
cames
donc je pense que malgré tout allié avec
le moine c'est plus intimiste je suis
allé lire plus d'empathie et donc je
pense que c'est plus logique alors
l'animateur de tf1 s'est dit extrêmement
blessé ils se sont trahis d'avoir autant
met en avant christian quesada c'est ce
que vous disiez un instant imaginer la
vérité vous imaginez pour moi la
blessure d'avoir mis quelqu'un comme ça
en avant une fierté de se dire c'est un
exemple c'était un exemple une chaque
fournisseur à l'époque faisait rêver
elle était extraordinaire chaque
personne se pouvait s'identifier en dix
ans cet homme est au rsa
ici il s'est débrouillé tout seul il a
arrêté en 4e exedra mais c'était un
exemple et là à aujourd'hui
imaginez vous la prudence la prévention
que nous nous devons de faire nous les
médias nous alors à votre avis est ce
que jean luc reichmann son voeu voilà
d'avoir de ne pas avoir réagi puisqu'il
va répondre à cette question dans un
instant en sus mais je vous pose la
question dit me mais il n'a pas à s'en
vouloir s'était pas écrit sur la tête
c'est dax était qu'il a fait ce qu'il a
fait c'est pas de la faute et je suis
mal à l'aise qu'on parle plus finalement
de quesada que finalement de la
pédophilie fait nos criminels
criminalité on fait comme si a manqué sa
taille mais il n'y en avait pas et
qu'après il y en aura pas moi je les
hais les gens veulent la justice la
justice qui remet en liberté ces
personnes et qui fait qu' on prend pas
de peine de prison
visite finalement suffisamment fer ont
suffisamment longtemps qui fait qu'on a
des prédateurs moi j'en veux à l'état
qui ne s'est pas mettre de côté protéger
nos enfants
je ne veux pas à tf1 je ne parle jamais
prêché man faut pas croire qu'une minute
que ils avaient une conscience qu'il ait
pu faire ce genre de choses donc pas de
procès d'intention sur jean luc
reichmann la prochaine intentions non
plus sur tf1 mais remettons nous en
cause il faut qu'enfin on fasse quelque
chose pour lutter réellement contre ça
alors justement durant l'interview donc
jean luc reichmann a révélé que s'il
s'en veut de n'avoir rien décelé chez
christian quesada pendant tout le temps
où il a côtoyé c'est vrai qu'il s'en
voulait un peu on aura la réaction aussi
de mathieu et de virginie aussi de jean
michel vous avez vous avez d'autres
carrefours garde de rien avoir vu et qui
plus est quand alors j'ai eu la chance
de travailler avec la brigade des
mineurs ils m'ont invité à l'époque quai
de gesvres et j'étais vraiment en
immersion avec eux ils m'ont dit mais tu
sais il faut faire attention
le plus attention aux personnes qui sont
le plus proches de toi que ce soit dans
le boulot que ce soit dans la famille
que ce soit dans l'école si cette
histoire peut permettre à nos enfants de
ne plus avoir cette pudeur
cette peur cette crainte de s'exprimer à
l'école avec tout ce qui se passe dans
dix ans et ben moi il ya quelque chose
que je ne sens pas si ça peut aider nos
enfants
je serai le plus heureux bien sûr jean
michel willot je vais répondre à jimmy
ont fait pas de procès d'intention ni à
jean luc reichmann via tf1 mais c'est
quand même normal vu l'ampleur du
scandale qui gonfleront shops on en
apprend un peu tous les jours c'est
normal qu'on se pose des questions
légitimes après l' enquête établira si
quelqu'un le savez ou pas mais c'est
quand même je pense que s'il y avait le
moindre doute son pic ne pensait que cet
homme était peut-être un pédophile qui
avait fait des choses supporte vraiment
qui serait dit non il a gagné 12
émissions 13 14 50 bien évidemment qu'on
leur arrêté je pense qu'on peut même pas
imaginer que dans leur tête
même le doute existe je pense qu'il
avait même pas de doute c'est un
concours impensable quand ils ont appris
à l'oeuf à la fin à la fin du jeu après
le jeu mais qu'ils ont pardonné à le
révéler les chiens a fait pendant durant
ses nombreuses battues pour être
stockées sont des dates de faire le
ménage dans ses réseaux sociaux en
milieu de démission c'est forcément
quelqu'un avait un doute
alors oui tombent sous le coup de la
passe et où le dénonce pas dans ces cas
là vous en avez dit une bêtise charge
optimus turbo alors attendre avant mais
pas parce que il ya jean luc reichmann
qui a avoué ressentir de la culpabilité
et il dit qu'il avait qu'il a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de mal à dormir au
début de la sphère regarde vous y
trouverez la culpabilité sur dedans donc
bien sûr je culpabilise parce que je me
suis dit comment j'ai pu passer à côté
de ça évidemment s'imaginer que je dors
bien en ce moment non je dors là ça va
beaucoup mieux
pourquoi parce que je pense qu'à
aujourd'hui il faut que tout le monde
arrête c'est pour ça que je suis là
aussi c'est que il ya une justice en
france
il faut laisser faire la justice et nous
que ce soit avec tf1 ou avec endemol
avec moi même qui suis animateur là
c'est de prendre toutes les précautions
pour que ça n'arrive plus
il a déjà premier point important il a
été condamné pour images
pédopornographiques et pas pour
pédophilie c'est important la tuer la
présomption d'innocence c'est pas la
même chose
exact je rejoins évidemment beaucoup
benjamin castaldi si on fait nettoyer le
facebook de quelqu'un on le comte sait
déjà qu'on a un doute et que si on ne
veut pas trop creuser c'est que ça nous
arrange un petit peu aussi pour
l'audience
et pardon je veux pas de gentils avec
jean luc reichmann que j'admire mais
jean luc reichmann il a fait un truc que
je n'aime pas du tout autour de cette
histoire vous allez vous énerver mais
tant pis je le dis il a laissé une bulle
qui se créé pendant trois semaines sans
parler pour qu'on attende la parole de
jean luc reichmann il par les réseaux
sociaux donc c'est pas une émission
et quand il a commencé à parler qu'est
ce qui dit j'ai été choqué la brigade
m'a appelé pour me dire il faut des gens
comme toi tu es bien tu es formidable y
ramène tout à lui
pardon j'aurais juste aimé de sa part et
je termine j'aurais juste new jersey
l'appareil j'aurais juste aimé de sa
part des excuses pour ce qu'on a vu à
l'antenne et qui ramène pas tout à lui
en faisant une bulle autour de lui mais
parce que moi ça me choque pourquoi des
excuses n'étaient pas au courant
qu'est ce que t'en sais on vient de
savoir qui leur ont même l'écouter
l'instant de fermer c'est pas pareil
la cantine les ramène tout à lui il faut
des gens comme toi mais il faut des gens
comme moi je n'en pardon mais draghi est
ce que voulait lui aurait dit mme diallo
là il est fou là il ya l'ouest non il ya
toujours une part de vrai dans ce que
dit à mathieu parce qu'il ya une sorte
de sensibilité très cher c'est vrai que
jean luc reichmann on l'a reçu ici c'est
quelqu'un de très talentueux qui avec a
beaucoup beaucoup de succès j'admire
énormément et c'est vrai qu'il est un
peu moi myself and high donc pardon
c'est un scoop que de le dire après moi
je le trouve extrêmement sincère je
trouve extrêmement justes dans tout ce
qu'il dit et je trouve que là pour le
coup ça ne souffre pas la contradiction
il trouve que c'est vraiment aller
chercher la petite bête
oui mais là vraiment je trouve que là
dans ce cas précis là là dans ce cas
précis il est au coeur de la faire
savoir son sentiment son ressentiment
sur cette affaire n'aurait pas l'aura
sur le facebook nettoyer comme mais amea
et non mais arrêtez minuit les mêmes
beaucoup je voudrais enfin quand tu sais
pas quoi dire comment je m'en suis pas
producteur si endemol qui produit alors
il s'en est pris aussi à tous ceux qui
s'expriment aujourd'hui sur la sphère en
prétendant qu'ils étaient déjà au
courant et ça je suis assez d'accord
avec 20 points tout le monde arrive là
maintenant moi j'ai un couteau quand je
te crois bas valais parler avant la
guerre et non avec la réserve dame
aujourd'hui je crois qu'il ya beaucoup
de gens qui parlent énormément au liban
je demande qui sont ces gens pourquoi
ils ont pas parlé avant pourquoi toutes
ces personnes qui parlent aujourd'hui
anne elisabeth ne m'ont pas prévenus -
jean-luc n'ont pas appelé tf1 n'ont pas
appelé la production endemol en disant
moi excusez moi j'ai déjà eu affaire à
cette personne là mais voilà je sens pas
l'histoire
pourquoi ces personnes arrive trois ans
après alors y est et on parle également
derrière patrice laffont qui avait
réagit il à réagir sur déclarations de
patrice laffont jean luc reichmann qui
lui avait dit cet été qu'il est qu'il
avait été blacklisté des chiffres réels
parce qu'ils le trouvaient sulfureux que
l'afl alors trouver si le führer et
dirige la guerre du match aller 2
pornographie barça pousse à faire une
enquête
mais chaque fois qu'on veut dire pas de
voisins et là ça me regarde tu vas
commencer une enquête mais vous ne vous
raconte pas de compter sur ses missions
de tf1 oui pas continuer sur ces
millions dans ton voisin fait sinon des
spectateurs je crois non non je connais
son voisin voilà voilà
si les cours regarder il a réagi aux
propos de patrice laffont garde il m'en
parle cet été pendant qu'on fait une
partie de pétanque qui m'ont dit ce mec
j'ai jamais sentie jeudi pardon alors
qu'ils étaient plus hard et le but un an
et demi deux ans mais avec des éléments
concrets où je n'ai pas du tout c'est à
dire voilà il était blacklisté bon bref
ont conduit une partie de pétanque
imaginez vous
donc voilà c'est tout ce qui s'est passé
je me suis effectivement voilà j'ai été
interpelé je me suis dit bon mais
pourquoi maintenant alors dans un
instant je vous montrais aussi la
dernière extrait il a il a répondu aux
rumeurs selon lesquelles la production
était au courant qu'est ce que vous
voulez ce que vous voulez réagir à ce
que vous voyez pas ce que vous le
découvrirez en moi c'est pas sûr
reichmann suis désolé je vais être un
peu mais c'est basique à dire mais on va
parler des victimes de minutes parce que
non pas assez d'accord sur marion une
astuce qui est un caméléon et donc
d'autres aussi d'ailleurs qui s'occupe
d'enfants qui ont été à toucher qui ont
été violées et aux philippines mais
malheureusement ça existe partout il ya
un moment il faut parler des victimes et
leur dire aujourd'hui avec tous les
acheteurs qui sortent limite wengo avec
vous tous les jours a dit exactement et
tout ce qu'on a vu aujourd'hui la parole
se libère et on peut aussi à un moment
si effectivement on voit des images
pédopornographiques ou des choses qui
sont choquantes je suis désolé de le
dire mais isabelle franchement ça me
choque et je réagis tu trouves le sujet
- je n'étais pendant les années étant
petit ouais donc je suis bien placé pour
voir en voyant ces images pour être la
première à réagir sur l'art genre de
choses eh ben je sais reconnaître un
homme relativement honnête sur ce genre
de choses
et là je dis car h mais n'y a rien à lui
reprocher noir une innovation 260 à bord
elle parle pas de ça je prépare
reichmann du tout elle pas de sécheval
territoire occupé alors la mort et la
raison en parlant du cas est en cours
alors tu les vois tu réagisses et
c'était à vomir